the public's nostalgia for retro
consoles has been growing over the last
several years
Nintendo kicked off a wave of
plug-and-play style systems with 2016's
Nest classic edition and followed up
with last year's snus classic now Sony
is looking to throw their hat in the
ring with the PlayStation Classic coming
next month
we got a hands-on look with this system
and want to give you our early
impressions let's start with the
hardware if you own a Ness or cest
Classic the PlayStation Classic will be
very familiar to you it's a miniature
version of the original system featuring
an HDMI port and micro USB for power in
the back and slots for two controllers
in the front the system's physical three
buttons all work as well the power does
well what you expect
turn the system on and off while the
reset button works the same as with
Nintendo systems bringing you back to
the main menu the interesting one is the
disk open button this is used when a
game needs you to switch discs it's
pretty cool that they found a way to
emulate the physical act of switching
the discs rather than having it happen
automatically instead of a proprietary
port the controllers plug in through USB
Sony said it doesn't feature support for
other controllers to be plugged in or
for the controllers to work on PC
although I figure some smart people will
figure that one out
the controller's themselves are based on
the original systems controllers that
means no analog sticks or Rumble support
we brought an original controller with
us for comparison and the classics
version feels very faithful it's just a
touch lighter in weight and the buttons
feel more clicky that's also probably
because we are comparing them to a 20
year old controller that seen lots of
use while I somewhat admire wanting to
stick to the nostalgia of the original
hardware I don't think anyone's gonna
argue that the Dual Shock wasn't a major
improvement over the original design and
it's disappointing that we won't have
the option to play with analog sticks or
Rumble in fact without them it will be
impossible to appreciate iconic moments
like the Psycho Mantis fight in Metal
Gear Solid
the menu is designed around the original
Playstations menus sporting a cool blue
background and that memorable rainbow
paint splatter behind the text when it
comes to settings the classic is very
bare-bones the system runs at 720p with
no options for resolution change or
adjustments to aspect ratio
there's no borders as well and no
filters such as scan lines while I
personally never use scan lines
preferring a sharper look there are
elements of menus and text of these
games that have an age gracefully and
scan lines could help make them look
less ugly the PlayStation Classic is
designed to just plug in and work with
no fuss but if you're looking for a bit
more control in your presentation you're
not going to get it here when you quit
out of a game a safe point is
automatically created that you can then
resume unlike the Ness and sus classic
there was only one save slot in each
time you reset you're asked if you want
to overwrite that save
there are however internal memory cards
that function just like the original
system they even use the same game icons
which is a great little touch the
PlayStation Classic comes with 20 games
with over 2,500 games released for the
system there was always gonna be some
personal favourites left out on the list
but even with that in mind we can't help
but be disappointed in the selection
missing iconic games like crash
bandicoot Symphony of the Night and tomb
raider games like Destruction Derby and
cool borders - are fine but not really
something we're itching to play of
course there are big names like Metal
Gear Solid Final Fantasy 7 twisted metal
Resident Evil director's cut and Tekken
3 there are also some neat cult classics
like odd world Abe's Oddysee
super Puzzle Fighter 2 turbo and Wild
Arms I think it's cool a game like
revelations persona is in the collection
even though I don't think the game has
aged all that well in fact many of these
early 3d games have an aged well and
your nostalgia is gonna be a big factor
in your enjoyment for games like Rainbow
six or cool borders too
as far as the technical side of how
these games are performing in our brief
time they seem to run as well as we
remember polygamous scaled on a modern
TV the same can't be said for certain UI
in other static images the rendered
backgrounds and Resident Evil suffer and
text and Ridge Racer is so blown out it
can be hard to read this isn't really a
fault of the PlayStation classic but
rather further evidence of how poor some
of these games have aged again this is a
case where a scanline filter might have
helped out unfortunately we couldn't do
any direct capture ourselves preventing
us from doing any actual comparisons to
original hardware overall our early
impressions are pretty mixed the
PlayStation Classic does exactly what it
intends letting you play these games at
a sharp 720p with a simple setup and no
fuss but the product feels a bit
bare-bones with no visual customization
and controllers that lack analog sticks
and Rumble support the game selection
certainly doesn't feel like the greatest
hits of the console the way the nests
and senesce classics did we'll be
putting the playstation classic through
its full paces next month when it
launches on December 3rd
[Music]